okay any questions so the question was
have I experienced any different
different differences between running
user surveys in person or online
honestly you'll probably figure out what
the best solution is for yourself online
honestly gets a lot of a lot of it right
I conduct a lot of interviews over zoom
I think it's again it depends kind of on
the context of the problem sometimes I
really find it powerful to stand behind
a user and ask them to use their
existing tools that can only really be
done kind of well if you're in person
but I have some soup I have seen some
people do that pretty effectively over
zoom as well there's something that I
keep in mind is um a UX researcher named
Jared spool and he talks about some
research where he says like he noticed
that in product teams products tend to
get worse over time if you find out that
the product and design teams are not
interacting directly with their users a
minimum every six weeks some amount of
time some set of hours and so it's one
of those things where it's like there's
just so much to be gained from like just
talking and having a small conversation
where it's like you just miss a ton of
stuff because it's like I don't know how
many surveys you fill out but the people
who do tend to fill surveys they fill a
very weird bucket oh yeah sorry I'm
mister I mistook the question it's just
you online or offline yeah no you
definitely need this open-ended
conversation with a user rather than
like a survey yeah absolutely so you
always want to supplement yeah
definitely
yes do you do you have any examples of
when your user is different from your
buyer so for example my startup involves
potentially selling in two countries so
I will be trying to get entire countries
to sign arguments to buy from me but
they will be the users of the products
are going to be the people in the
country so Who am I
yeah yeah we should repeat the question
yeah the question was what happens if
the users of your product are different
from the buyers and in the context of
the asker she was asking whether or
country's countries maybe the people
using it but the buyer may be an
individual yeah this is a tough problem
this usually calls for more user
interviews so the best the best answer
here is just to have conversations with
different people in the buying chain
remember that a great user interview is
not actually a sales pitch
it's actually learning more about the
context in which that person encounters
the problem so in your case I might
consider having several different layers
of interviews with potential buyers
potential users of the product potential
influencers oftentimes in an enterprise
sale there are some people in the buying
chain that aren't even involved in using
the product whatsoever but they have a
say in maybe the budget or the time
frame in which they'll purchase or use
new solutions and so it helps to
actually have conversations with them as
well so you can get context around maybe
past attempts that they've tried to
solve this problem you know millions of
dollars that they've already spent that
went down the drain and you can and you
can learn like how they may be helpful
or how they may hinder your sales
process in the future just quick add so
that I would say for the economic buyer
in the company or whoever government or
whatever it is talking to them and
trying to understand how they're going
to make the decision and what they
actually value is probably most
important the only thing I would add to
that is that when you're talking to your
user there's usually like in a complex
b2b enterprise transaction you have
someone that's acting as your champion
someone who's like super excited by
using the product usually their user
and/or there's someone are like I don't
have to do this anymore if you you get
implementor about by my company and so
you need to use them as your like Virgil
like you're gonna basically say like
help me map out who's all involved who
needs to be in the room and what are
their sort of motivations and so you're
basically looking to get Intel for all
that process and then the whole question
is like you need to have all the
arguments for things that they sort of
care about one of the hacks that I like
to use that this
and it helps if you're still in
university but you can actually kind of
talk to big companies as if you were say
the reporter for a school newspaper or
if you were working on a school project
you can use this as like a hack to
actually get a pretty high level contact
with someone who might become a champion
simply by kind of saying like I'm just
really excited about budget management
software I would love to learn more
about this I know that you you work on
this a lot and so you can actually like
interact and and and talk to people at a
pretty high level before you even
announce that you're working on a
solution for that it's like how much
money do you control for your budget
oh so for some of us we've already lost
we're already talking to a bunch of prop
users a week but as we scale that might
get beyond what any one person can talk
how do you I slit down the subset of
users they want to interview the
question is get the scale how do you
like segments just the users what what's
the reason for segmenting these you know
housewives in know they might have
different you know feedback that some of
those Housewives you so there's a couple
good tools for helping if you'd like
having oh the question is like basically
how do you say let's say you have a
really broad audience that you're trying
to figure out what are their use cases
how do you best handle that segmentation
so that way you get useful feedback to
know like specific direction of the
product so there's a couple useful tools
that I have used in the past and I've
recommended to other people so Google
consumer surveys and Survey Monkey
audience so both of those you can ask
really simple questions and choose the
demographic survey monkey is actually a
bit more expensive but they actually
have proper survey methodology that
actually will balance it out based on
like US population so for example most
people will fill out surveys let's say
for money or for nonprofits it's mostly
skewed towards women and they tend to be
older
so like if you were to ask Google
consumer surveys a lot of that stuff
will tend to be skewed that way and for
them you can actually specifically
handle it and they'll actually use
statistics to sort of balance it out so
that's number one it's like directly
asking I tend to not for broad product
do you like a general surveys usually
it's almost always to my direct users to
figure out like okay who seems to be
just already a fan of my product like
who have I accidentally acquired who's
like a superfan I'm trying to figure out
I don't get more of you and then I'm
doing everything I can get them to talk
to me so I'd rather like I will spend
like 50 bucks on a gift card they get
that user to have a conversation with me
so I understand who he is and see if
there's ways that I could multiply him
and one of the things to remember is
like never remember that you know as the
founder of a company you can actually
reach out directly personally to any one
of your users and ask if you could just
jump on the phone and chat with them
this is like something that is kind of
crazy because you know no big complex
offs not going to do this Facebook's not
going to this this is a competitive
advantage that you as kind of a small
early-stage company have you as the the
product creator the founder can actually
have a direct connection with any user
in your user base
some people productize this and do like
tons and tons of emails but other others
just choose to have maybe 10
conversations or 20 conversations with
individual users every week yeah one of
the things I always do if you have
enough data in your case like lots of
customers is for is to start tabulating
for each customer figure out the
characteristics of each one like female
where they live
income level so and so forth and if you
have all the emails it's there's
actually services out there that you can
qualify all these people and then after
that bucket all the customers until like
here my best customers here are the ones
that paid me 100 bucks or more and then
try to find patterns and then go
segments that way and talk to those
people and like Kevin said how do I get
more people who naturally pay me more
what are the patterns what do they do
every day and offer them gift cards or
whatever to do these are interview
sessions I would aim like if you have
enough data and you have enough those
types of people I worked really a m-- to
do
a session once a week with a handful of
people it's I find that's the most
informative thing the best thing you can
do for your business and it's just like
an in-person session it can be or can be
over the phone it doesn't be in person
depending on the product so let's say
you have an MVP belt you're starting to
do this music interview you're listening
and not talking when do you do the sales
pitch to playoff fedoras point once you
begin to understand within your user
base who are the best users who are the
people that that are the most
disappointed if they couldn't use your
product anymore who the ones that get
the most benefit you can actually go
sideways and you can try to dig deep and
find more people that reflect the same
kind of demographic some of the tips or
tricks that we use it's like where do
those people live on the internet which
subreddits do they use which Facebook
pages do they follow which which kind of
other services do they already use and
then you can like use the the
fingerprint of the users you already
know to find more and find out where
they live online so my strategy would be
if I was in that case and I had a
wonderful user and interview with them
and a turn it's looking like oh god what
I've built is perfect for this person so
instead of being like I feel like it's
the wrong moment to be like ah gotcha
here's my thing I'd rather be like I'd
go home maybe wait a day or two and be
like oh my God thank you so much for the
conversation that we had and based on
what you talked about I built the first
version of this I would love for you to
check it out and let me know what you
think it's totally based on your
feedback and it's more likely that
they're gonna be honored their ego
stroked and then we're likely to use it
so to me I feel like that gives you
maximum benefit versus it feels like did
you even care about me at all
was this really a sales pitch hidden
that's it exactly and that's what you
don't want to have after like being such
a conscientious like empathetic listener
and know
that quick a programmer that they
programmed it while they were talking
yes right here yes I was yet the AMA
when I saw you about the comment
regarding beta releases and I was
curious to hear more of your thoughts
about why you should release of beta we
want to limit people that are on the
platform just havethey people or talk to
so in the AMA I kind of who boop beta
versions or labeling your project as
beta to artificially constrain growth on
your product and so the main idea for me
is that it creates like an affordance it
basically is a sign that says my
products not ready for you don't use me
because it's not ready for production
expect bugs etc and the reason a lot of
founders or engineers like to put beta
on theirs because it's it's like hey you
know what this I know it's not that good
I built it myself I know how many bugs
there are and I'm so scared of people
being disappointed so if I put this beta
on it's just going to remove all
liability and to me I feel like there's
no product I've ever seen in production
that doesn't have bugs and almost always
the what good founders do is they listen
to the people they respond to the bugs
they fix it as quick as possible and
even in your beta you will probably do
the same so to me I see no reason why
you need to do that is to put that beta
on so I don't like anything that
artificially can change growth because
like all that stuff you're gonna do for
the beta to be a good founder listening
fixing etc you're going to do that even
in production so that's number one
the second thing about beta is that
you're gonna spend your whole company's
life trying to get as many users as
possible and so if you're thinking like
I've built something so good that if I
don't put beta on there there's gonna
just going to be overwhelmed with demand
I'm gonna tell you that the hypothesis
is probably wrong
at all and so again if something does go
wrong or some certain issue that you're
actually super scared of like don't have
that feature reveal if something does go
wrong just like hey thank you so much
I've only been working on it a week or
I've only been working on in a month I'm
gonna fix it really quickly and then get
it back to you please let me know if you
find anything else and then you're more
likely to get a more positive response
and people actually using it the way
that you're hoping you might find people
use it as a result I like real world
honest test about do people want this
thing and then is my thing ready yeah
the real fear that founders need to get
over is okay I've built something crap
people are gonna come if it's like not
good enough they're never going to come
back like hopefully you're building a
business that will but millions of
people can use anyway and so just the
four or five people that come back or
sorry the four people to calm and don't
have a good experience get that feedback
and then just iterate towards something
better you don't have to worry about
them not coming back and I think that's
actually one of the main reasons why
most people don't watch early or they
put beta tags on everything so how do
like hey I can stop interviewing and
then just stop feeling I mean like
economy interviews but like maybe people
say you know 100 but the ones that we
also women that I can start I wouldn't
do it wait for a hundred to me they're
going to happen in concert with one
another oh yeah so the question is like
okay how many interviews do I have to do
before I start building etc and so if
you don't have anything built you don't
even really know like what the solution
should needs to be you're just trying to
figure out what is the problems set out
there you basically do inner user
interviews until you have an insight be
like I think I can build something that
will solve the problem and then you
immediately start building but for the
most part you want to do them in
parallel and just to jump in Kevin
offered a framework to think about is
the problem that I'm facing or is the
solution to the problem big enough to be
a company you can actually extract that
from those early user interviews more
effectively than after you
a product because you're not biased by
thinking like I already like this I have
a great idea already you can actually be
in that kind of pure mode where it's
like is this a real problem is this
really a burning problem that people are
facing when do you charge I love it
early and often as early as possible and
so like if you can get away with taking
a pre-order wonderful if you're building
like we often give advice to companies
who are considering making a complex
like b2b enterprise app we're like go
try to sell that first before you go
commit six to twelve months make it it's
putting it's asking people to put their
money where their mouth is
remember how I said before that
oftentimes users don't really know what
they want they won't be able to describe
the future product but they will be able
to know it when they see it and at that
point you can extract data from them by
saying well this person has the problem
so acutely that they want to solve it
that they're willing to pay some random
startup that has not even like it
doesn't even have a product if they're
willing to pay them that's like a very
strong signal that you're on to
something
Eric's model for talking to users it's
very similar to what the best
salespeople actually do when they're
trying to sell their product they're
truly trying to understand the users are
potential customers problems and then
they're immediately trying to craft is
like oh yeah we've got that we're able
to solve that they able to reposition
their product back to them and so this
is why you're able to actually for even
complex enterprise software if you truly
understand the user or talk to them
you're like oh absolutely we could
totally build that we can have that this
time frame and I think we can do it at
this cost would that be something of
value to you would you like to sign a
contract and have us committed we can
start with a patron or whatever like the
whole thing is like through the idea you
can sell it to the right customer if
they believe that you're capable and
that you truly are going to build
something of value to them and so I did
something where like for my first
product even before pebble we set up a
landing page with Shopify or we set
about we set up a sales cart where
people could actually go through the
checkout process to buy the product we
didn't feel comfortable about charging
people's credit cards but we made the
the
checkout process look exactly like they
would have to pay so we figured we would
get a better signal from those users
instead of just like an email signup
form like hey are you interested they
actually went through the flow thinking
that they were gonna have to pay
something and at the end we said like oh
we're actually accepting payment in a
couple weeks but at that point they were
already so invested in me we think that
it was a more effective way of kind of
gauging interest so he's asking is like
the open source model where we you
release a product out for people to
start using for free as a way of like
building up an audience that you
eventually will sell to like is that
pretty much how that model works and so
I think for most of the successful open
source like base companies like say for
like it get lab yes that's pretty much
how it works they're thinking of
building up an audience I think for us
like that advice for us came directly
from Jason freed of 37signals so he had
talked about this story at South by
Southwest doing big things with small
teams and they had been blogging for
years on their blog 37signals weeper
front before they finally launched base
camp and they realized like that was
super valuable to them because people
didn't start from zero when evaluating
their product they felt like they
already had a relationship with these
people and there were all the exact kind
of people the audience that they knew
that they were building for the segment
story is pretty good in this way as well
yeah yeah so the the founding of its
kind of segment the story around how
segments got started they actually
created an open source library that
analytics taught Jas that that you can
embed into your website and it would
kind of duplicate all of your analytics
to or would send analytics from your
site to all of the different existing
kind of aggregators and was open-source
project became like just went crazy on
Hacker News and they ended up using that
as a way to then sell the rest of their
offering from there I think it was like
a crazy small number of lines in the
first version and then the CEO at the
time was like not a [ __ ] chance
nobody wants your stupid little code why
are we announcing this and never came
the whole company and then it like just
went by oh it just went nuts like people
in hacker D's just couldn't get enough
of it people were actually how do I get
access to this code etc and then that
became the counterpoint to the charge
money early because that was a free
open-source project that had no no
business model whatsoever at the
beginning but again got a bunch of users
them their figure out like okay how do I
charge how do I turn this into I love I
love talking about this because this is
a problem that comes up all the time so
especially for hardware companies but I
would have tracked the problem - the
question - like broader like if your MVP
actually takes a lot of work to do if
there's a lot of building that needs to
happen before you can offer kind of that
first modicum of value to users how do
you do that do you do a paper prototype
etc so the I love this because I think
that there are great ways that you can
hack around this problem it's very easy
to say like oh I'm building you know the
super complex piece of software or
hardware I need to spend at least two
years before I can talk to customers or
before I could find out whether they're
interested in buying this that is not
sure you can start talking to customers
on day one and here's how talk about the
existing ways that they're solving this
problem figure out what are the products
they currently use to solve it and
figure out what the pain points what the
problems are
from there the way the
you validate that they're interested in
buying something is hack together
off-the-shelf existing technology that
kind of approximates the problem
obviously it's not going to be as
amazing as your beautifully designed
perfect thing that you're working on but
you'll get an approximation of it show
that approximation show that hack to the
person who just described it they have a
problem and try to sell it dress up
other people's technology as your own
like put it together put your own 3d
printed box on it you know duct tape it
together put your name on it and try to
sell it because what I've learned is
that if people aren't even interested in
buying or using the hack together
solution then the thing that you're
gonna work on for two years may not
actually be like that much of a solution
to the problem that makes it exciting
like really if you're working on a
problem that's so burnin that's such an
acute problem the user should be willing
to work with like a kind of crappy hack
together solution before you finish your
real one you can do so much with a
landing page just understand interest
whether your message the idea resonates
they'll be excited they see a light if
they have such a burning problem they
see a landing page for like this this
product that finally solves their you
know Wayas hopes and dreams like they'll
get in touch with you I think the other
thing is like Dropbox actually started
that way so Dropbox was launched as an
After Effects movie that approximated
what the experience was going to be like
the shared Dropbox and then everyone
went nuts is like I want to know when
that software is available and it like
almost no lines of code would have
actually been written and so it was
basically a product demo that company
[Music]
[Applause]
so the question is you know it's harder
to get a consumer product out there like
the digital space on Instagram Facebook
everywhere it's getting much more
expensive and it's true I see a ton of
like new products that are launching on
Instagram and I keep thinking like how
much money that they pay to get one ad
in front of me it's it's crazy
so what what can you do at at an early
stage without that much money kind of
going back to the theme of this this
talk you can talk to users talking to
users that actually pretty cheap because
people on an individual basis are
probably willing to pick up the phone
and talk to someone like like I said
before often times like they've never
talked to a tech CEO they've never
talked to someone who could actually
build a solution to their problem so if
you position yourself as someone who may
actually be able to help them they may
talk to you just for free because they
they see an opportunity just as a side
note like often times when I talked to a
founder who's working on a product that
may potentially help me I know that
they're potentially willing to build
like the exact thing that I want if I
just tell them that and so you may find
people that are willing to kind of open
open up the kimono and and share that
for free in kind of that's that's kind
of a way to get a couple users to talk
you if you want to get more in aggregate
the most scalable ways that we've seen
work for our founders are really like
putting yourself in the in the
demographic of interested users and
figuring out where they live in the
world whether that means like in in the
physical world like we have companies
that hanged or tags on on houses because
that's like an effective way of getting
people's attention and kind of the
digital equivalent of that is
infiltrating communities where people
who share who have this problem are
sharing their thoughts like often times
there's a Facebook group about a
particular medical condition or like a
particular travel destination and it's
actually pretty effective to just kind
of like position yourself as an expert
in the space and kind of organically
enter and be part of that community
we're gonna add in questions so you guys
got 15 minutes to talk to one another
thank you so much for coming to the
first lecture we're gonna stick around
for a little bit and then we have to
clear out of this room but enjoy and we
will see some of you on Saturday in New
York and then back here again on
Wednesday bye guys
[Applause]
you